Okay so now I want to pick this up
and talk about the project operator. So a couple of
things to note about project, we can use project to
include fields from the original document. Remember that project works
with data in a single document at a time. And
we're essentially doing a shaping task with project. So the
simplest form of shaping, is simply specifying which fields from
each of the documents we're receiving in the stage using
project, we would like to include and pass along
to the next stage. One really cool thing we can
do with project, is insert computed fields. So, for
example, a ratio, which is what we're going to do
for this particular example we're working through. We might
also rename fields. And finally, we can do some pretty
substantial reshaping of the data, by doing something like
creating fields that hold subdocuments that are composed of what
were originally top level fields in the documents,
as they came into the stage using the project
operator. So let's go back to our code,
and look at how we're using project here. Remember,
the problem we're trying to solve here is,
addressing the question who has the highest followers to
friends ratio? So here, it's pretty straight forward, we're
simply pulling out the screen name field of the
user sub-document. Okay? And again, we use this
$ here, because rather than this being interpreted
as just a string literal, we're telling mongoDB
that we want the value. For each document
that's found in the user sub-document and in
the screen name field. Okay? So, in documents
that get passed along from this particular stage,
they will have a screen name field composed of
that value for each document that we received
as input here. Okay, now let's look at this
portion of the projected stage here. So we're going
to create a ratio field and documents that come
out of this particular stage. And that ratio
field is going to have the value of having
divided the followers count by the friends count, so
quite literally, calculating this ratio here. Again, remember friends,
in the documents we're looking at here, are the
number of people that I follow as opposed to
people who follow me. Okay, so again, diving into
the user sub-document, we're going to pull out the
followers account, and the friends account. Again making use
of the dollar operator here to indicate we actually
want the values of each of these. And then
we're going to use the divide operator to calculate the
ratio of these two values. It's that value
then, that will make up the value of the
ratio field in each document that gets passed
along from this stage using the project operator. Okay,
so when we get to this stage all
documents will have exactly two fields: ratio and screen
name. And then we're simply going to sort in
descending order based on ratio, and then of course,
limit to just the very first document that
we see. So let's run this. Okay, and again.
Our output from an aggregation inquiry is always
a single document. The results we're really interested in
are always in the result field, which is an array value field. Okay? So,
in this case, user in our tweets collection that has the highest
followers to friends ratio, is a user called Twitterific.
' Kay, turns out this is actually a Twitter application,
and even today if you look at Twitterific's page on Twitter,
you'll see that they have something on the order of nearly
half a million followers. But they only follow about 14 people,
so their followers to friends count ratio is still extremely high.
So again, in this example, we focused on the $ match
operator, which is just a filter, the $project operator, which is
a shaping operator, we actually have lots of things that we
can do here. And the sort and limit operators. So
in this case we've got four stages of our pipeline.
Now one thing before I wrap this up, is I
just want to quickly point out that we can build a
variety of expressions using the Project operator. If we take
a look at the MongoDB documentation, there are a number
of arithmetic operators that we can apply, as well as
a number of string operators, date operators and so on.
So this is the aggregation expression operators page in the docs. I encourage
you to look here for more information on the different types of operators
that are available to you when working with Project, as well as the
other aggregation framework operators. See the instructor
notes for a link to this page.